[Music]
would any of you guys
ever try to drink your own urine no why
are you going to pay medication
you're going to pay me i'll do it no if
it's life and death i would like for you
i think i would have to be like on the
brink of death
oh like it's like if you were like
trapped under rubble after an earthquake
or whatever and you're like i need to
eat and your name is james franco
how are you going to do it you got to
piss in your hand like this and go yeah
i don't know
well if you're a guy you just point it
up yeah no
no you're gonna if i'm wearing clothes
i'll probably pee on my clothes and then
just bring it oh that's
that's smart that's really really i hope
you just suck it out is this under the
assumption that we don't have a cup
yeah no yeah because i was picturing
just like making a puddle of urine and
just like slurping on it because that's
how [ __ ]
like on the brink of death i am oh like
you just you're just on the floor
like i'm super down it just all depends
on the circumstance i see it i don't
know
why am i dying i might do it like once
in my life just to know regardless of
life involved oh [ __ ]
just to taste it really we do it today
for video for our patreon
i don't know about like maybe when i'm
like super old you know when you're like
really
fun what you just want to taste and then
by then your taste buds are all [ __ ]
up so you can't really taste it yes
and your pee is going to be all brown
i'm actually trying to taste it
compare it to so you got to try young
people it's more the story
it's more understanding wasn't there a
thing called urine therapy that
a lot of fitness people were doing
drinking
i knew someone um a indonesian man that
would tell me
that he would he would get like vitality
and feel like you know what i'm talking
about vitality the security guard that i
used to work with the
charles jr you guys don't want that
actually yes i was so tight with him he
was the cutest jolliest man yeah he was
like in his 50s or whatever
you know why i look so young and smell
like a piss
yeah i drink the pizza and because i
know that he like he likes talking
clothes too
hey how are you doing i'm always like oh
[ __ ] get away from me
no he was too cute i didn't care he was
cute i don't want to have a piss on my
face
well he was like you're in you're in
you're in nice very very nice very nice
very nice so yeah so
a plus i'm talking about specifically
urine therapy
and it's called there's a term for it
it's called uh urotherapy
euro like a european like you are
european
bro like urologist yeah yeah exactly
but euro therapy and recently a guy went
viral
for live streaming his ritual
which is to drink his own urine and he
claims
it's warded off illnesses and mitigated
his depression he
started drinking pee because he had
depression and he found
found this through um there was an it's
an indian philosophy
and it was basically a [ __ ] reform
[ __ ] oh here we go
i can imagine all the indians watching
this and they're like nah bro
we don't do that [ __ ] i know shivambu
kalpa it's a concept of urine therapy
said to have originated in india and and
so this guy named yan
it's right next to the kama sutra at the
library uh there we go does he drink it
like
fresh from his body or does he put like
ice cubes in it
like pasteurize it he's not shaking it
yeah she mixes it with jubi matcha
oh there we go that's nice why can't he
just do
pills or something pee-pee pills pee-pee
pills it's not the thing
he takes it out he has to put it in the
middle every time yeah maybe pills he
looks pissed
yeah so that's a lot why is it not just
a [ __ ] shot it's like a lemonade
it does look like lemonade i wonder if
it's hot warm i brought his breast milk
would you [ __ ] him nah okay who's that
question directed to
bart yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah this guy was you know dealing
with depression and whatnot
and it makes sense i mean like hey if
you had to drink pee
every day everything else seems like
ease you know what i mean
yeah that's where that's where the
therapy came from some indian dude was
like you know what
if you could start your morning drinking
some [ __ ] peepee
then the rest of the day doesn't seem so
bad this [ __ ] looks like urine right now
like damn oh
true yeah why did i say it like that why
why why why why why
and if you drink your pee and you're
still depressed take it till next time
start eating your dookie
yeah start your morning with dookie you
can't get worse than that you're worse
than this
really like i'm curious what the science
is behind
urine therapy because i eat [ __ ] man
it's like i already did
no but like urine is your waist like
you're in his lips don't be so pissy
about it oh there's electrolytes in it
is there i don't know i mean urine is
literally your waist maybe he's peeing
out all this happiness and he's bringing
it back
you know it's like he's been wasting
happiness all his life that's why
so system isn't good at holding on to
happiness yeah
and then so it's letting it all out so
he needs to bring it back in the morning
what's the science behind this none
okay i don't know i think this is like
pseudoscience for sure [ __ ] it you know
how your pee gets like highlighter
yellow when you
when you eat yoshinoya you take what
those are the vegetables bro
do they wait you know what vegetables
get your pee like
it makes the rice highlighter that
vegetable goo
yay i know i don't know why that's true
that's true yeah it's like grabbing like
that wasted vitamins and then drinking
it
like so it's just recycled vitamins well
i read up a little bit about it and
um were you curious yeah because i'm
like why would people think drinking
their own piss
is is gonna make them healthier right
and then i guess
we do waste a lot of stuff in the pee
pee that we can absorb back again
right but i'm just like just take
[ __ ] vitamins again yeah why don't we
just eat the [ __ ] that
we've like let out from a survival
perspective they do so you could drink
your pee like two or three times
really uh a day you know like if you
drink it like let's say you don't have
you're not hydrated right
and then you get stuck somewhere you pee
pee in a bottle you could drink that and
then once you pee again you could drink
that again but then after that then
that means your toxicity is too hot so
high the pea it's getting darker and
darker darker and darker yeah yeah yeah
yeah
whatever it's getting more things more
concentrated yeah yeah so i mean does
that mean
when you pee out and oh this is really
clear today
i should drink this yeah it looks like a
beer like ice cold beer
yeah then you drink it you piss it and
you're like oh okay my body's good now
yeah yeah you put it in the ice train
you make popsicles
it's a pisicle if you were in a world
where you're going to try this
right would you drink it fresh
like no no body type warmth i would or
would you freeze it or make a cold or
add some ice cubes
i got to do it i gotta try it from the
source so if i could even put my penis
in my mouth i would i'll probably add
oh my god bart starts sucking it wait
this kind of feels good
he ends up nutting instead of being like
whoa i didn't ask for a pee
float pee pee flow
oh very creative i see the white
filament
oh god that's disgusting it's like beer
oh yeah oh yeah you just you gotta like
carbonate it
oh it's true though if you like
carbonate and ice your pee
how do you gotta shake your little
bladder a little bit get some bubbles
i wonder what it tastes like water it's
probably salty right because
the more i mean you're just constantly
regulating water and salts in your body
joe how much money do i have to give you
none i might do it just experiment but
i'm not gonna chug it
i might like piss on my hand and lick it
and go oh okay that might be nasty that
might be good
i want to get a gulp of it like yeah you
can't see then you got like a possibly
salty sweaty hand that's like affecting
the taste of it
true you know you gotta like take it put
it why eat [ __ ] what's that like
cubes a little clamato and then like
definitely not like piss
yeah but when you suck a little bit of
dick right doesn't there a little pee
pee there no
without a gulp of it no probably no yeah
yeah i mean like when you're just hot
and steamy and then it was like he just
peed you know what
no essence
of that to like the surface area of like
everything else in the epidermis that
probably will
counter that amount of piss taste but
like a whole cup
you need more like you need like a whole
cup to like get the therapy yeah your
mouthwash i understand like that
yeah like a shot glass full of it i
don't know man the smell of pee just
pisses me off
i still need to understand what the
beneficial properties are
i don't think they don't break it down
they just says it's if it helps with
depression
and wards off illnesses this guy even
applies pee to skin
eyes and even his head he smells [ __ ]
yeah you know what else helps this
depression
go into a theme park though i'd rather
do that than [ __ ] drink some people
what a therapy dude like therapy
they're a pee that's what they should
call a therapy
therapy or peen part that's good
ammonia urea and water it's all the
things that don't smell good yeah
isn't it our waste like our [ __ ] and our
piss like it's just
our bodies like yeah we don't need this
much yeah exactly just like
let's it's waste right mm-hmm but i mean
i guess
he thinks that there's some other
components there that is just
way better than that it's working for
him [ __ ] it yeah would you rather
would you rather drink your own pee or
someone else's yeah or someone
else's well who's whose else is [ __ ] no
is it like a hobbit is it like a
celebrity else's audrey
no i'll drink crippy all day amazing
thank you honestly whatever they do it's
always going to be clean for some reason
like
psychologically a healthy a healthy hot
girl
i would drink that before i drink my own
piss that
is a lot cause some of the [ __ ] that if
she ate
if she ate some bad food i'll be like
telling i'll be judging i'll be like
i hope you eat more vegetables and [ __ ]
like you're drinking
you're still eating this though that's
cool asparagus pizza
i'll [ __ ] with that all day it's so bad
when you pee after it yeah asparagus pee
or coffee pee or pineapple pee pineapple
coffee pizza bad it'll be like i haven't
i've never had pineapple pee
i don't think i've ever had pee but i
mean
no no no no i've never peed out
pineapple smells yeah i'm like
i i don't think i have pineapples right
now i'll pee
tonight just eat the [ __ ] what about
when you take b complex and then your
p's like
really like dark does that mean that's
the good p
oh brown dark or what do you mean really
dark not brown
probably i think you might be bleeding
internally bro no i never said brown
like it looks like a little b complex
it's like a lot more like a
yellowish orange amberg yeah amber is a
good word
like is that the color of your energy
oh my god oh my god it's that time of
the day folks
but yeah so um he says that after
drinking pee his lifestyle changed where
he only needs four
he's really he removed all the toilets
from his house
i don't need these anymore
what about the [ __ ] though yeah he only
needs the garden he eats the vegetables
after
four to seven hours a night which i'm
thinking seven hours
we all sleep seven hours that's a random
scale four to seven
yeah like i don't i don't get that after
i started drinking my pee
i was able to sleep like a regular
person
[Laughter]
i mean compared to what like one hour a
night yeah maybe had insomnia before or
maybe he
overslept he slept too much maybe or is
he sleeping like eight hours
there's gotta be like pea fetish people
right that are like about this he's like
whoa this guy
wants to put pee all over his skin and
his eyes and stuff like
i love peeing on people like the golden
shower community i don't know if p
fetish people even want to consume pee a
lot like if you want maybe they don't
want to consume maybe they're down for
somebody else to consume theirs oh maybe
yeah you know
they want to give not take pee this is a
lot better though than that one chick we
talked about
here on the show where she was drinking
her dog's urine
oh collecting her dog's pee and drinking
it
i'd probably drink dog pee before human
pee though like a stranger
yeah cause they have a short wait a
minute they have like shorter intestines
it doesn't have to it doesn't stay in
their bladder as long as it does for a
human
so it's just they smell bacteria i don't
know it's a beastiality
i'm not pistility but you're right
thank you they might be healthier thank
you shorter intestines shorter system
yeah what about like the
animals plp rights activists no no no
no i mean like animal bacteria or
whatever that's
i guess we consume animals if you drink
german shepherd pee is that considered a
german brew
yeah a heaven this is like a chinese
beer because it came from a cha-cha
[Music]
do
you